[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] on it must fail.
Then number two does not
take away a concierge Javier,
cause y'all meet at West
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Huh?
[inaudible] ets. It falls
[inaudible] convenience, Huh?
Ooh.
Oh.
Can we say
[inaudible] [inaudible]
off your phone call.
Got It all to the [inaudible].
Pretty awesome.
Memorial toasted
compossible possible oxygen.
No, no, no ma'am.
All your fit planet.
Jeez.
All phones pulled out upon this.
[inaudible] know to say Katrina
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] he owned them since he
is actually Louis
[inaudible].
I think so.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] not yesterday.
[inaudible] Fox.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Sandy.
Sit that back
together.
[inaudible] powerful
two [inaudible]
it does something necessa could get
the wea called tobacco and bullshit.
That call she had the SUV,
the muscle glassy.
He can put butter dentistry
[inaudible] game. Is it
[inaudible] dot com Warner RSP don't
diminish the requests on disease.
I mean,
you don't feel
as you began.
The buck does been minute.
She's hot. Mosley upon
request. Was that be so
I could know.
No [inaudible] will be squishy.
Treated them.
[inaudible]
she told us,
she told us on two, nine, five
c Twitter too naive. I bought
it. That's your fastest
picked condom. Male. The norm on
Sunday to Tucson.
Sit this sampler. Amal. Component. Busy.
He usually
no,
Ellen.
Hello?
Yeah.
Movie Bad.
Good job.
No.
Uh,
these honey
elitism.